hello and welcome to this video playing
black against grandmaster whole raid
can we check briefly who that is no it's
no name in there
okay don't don't mean that many gm's
here on in that leeches pool
okay so against the tromb i still play
what i recommended back in the day
in my bankroll gambit
repertoire
interesting e3
knight c6 or taking both look
fine i i have really forgotten the
details
this looks odd though why would you
allow knight e4 under those
circumstances
interesting because right cannot
i mean taking looks looks so sorry
this and this looks dubious because i
attack his knight
and if the nine moves d4 is dropping at
the same time i'm threatening to
damage his pawn structure taking the
bishop and queen a5
is also a bit annoying so a little bit
of a surprising choice here by the grand
master
i think normally instead of knight f3
they take on f6
at least that's what i remember okay so
let's take
knight to e5 okay
so i could take here
and check it's probably
nothing special though taking on d4
knight c6 hmm not
clear that this
gives me anything special
okay i'm sorry i just got a message for
my
from my system um that was distracting
okay now let's make a decision here i
can also check on a5
but this is also just equal maybe this
is still okay for white i thought
i might be better there
queen a5 there's also just c3 so
interesting so what am i actually
playing here
taking
yeah i don't know it's a bit strange i
thought i would have chances to be a
little bit better here but
it seems to be absolutely not the case
i wanted to take and play bishop b7 but
that's actually
risky due to
um a due to e6 interesting
maybe flick this in
i don't know i spent ages here in this
position
and
it's not really good
this bishop b5 is also a deeply
disturbing move really
sometimes i have to be really uh careful
that i'm not
walking into into such a move
something like bishop moves queen d1
rook t1 bishop
d7 there is e6 that is really
oh i can actually go
maybe to c6 oh it doesn't look good
strange really strange i understand why
he's taking time because
my position looks really it looks shaky
it looks like there could be something
really serious going on and
i take a6
and this rook d5 okay
anyway i have to make more i'm just so
much down here
on the clock it's increment
but
e6 runs into a mate
wants to go bishop d5 i guess
this one then e6
okay
it's still under pressure i mean
h4 rook g8
this is actually okay for me if nothing
bad happens in the next
next two or three moves let's say
then i'm okay
this is one of those famous last words
situations
so bishop here bishop h5
i just see that pretty annoying
okay maybe i have to do this
trying to get rid of one rook maybe king
e2 for white
king e2 rook h1
and pile up more
lending more cover to that pawn
here yeah
okay but that is not so important
i'm still covering everything here
check
checking his rook
on h6
he's attacking e6 now so
covering this
it takes f8 i can take with check so
this one
gets traded
bishop c6 it's just a check so
i'm going to grab this pawn
go here
check again
i want to just gain a bit more time
this
okay king over to b8
and maybe rook h2 was correct yeah when
winning a bit more time there
i don't mean on the clock like
i cannot take a3 because of cover it
here
now attack f4
right it look it should be a draw at the
end of the day
unless he drums up something
against my king
yeah well it doesn't look like i can do
anything here
white is too active
ah king c5 why am i actually doing that
i was completely unnecessary
okay
i offered him a draw no draw
what
this is increment chess
okay it was a bit strange
um that was a bit
weird i mean there were probably chances
for him to kill me i'm fairly certain
but i'm a little bit surprised that
that i didn't um get anything here it
seems that
knight before by looking good at first
glance isn't all that great
[Music]
so i don't have anything here right
queen b6 seems to be the best move
didn't consider that all that much but
it looks
pretty reasonable okay h6
and now i took this on d1
and a6 yeah bishop b5 was a really
annoying looking move
and what i was really afraid of bishop
d7 i was afraid of e6 in this
position the engine is just keeping its
cool and says f takes but
i was really concerned about this pawn
structure
maybe it doesn't matter i mean the main
concern is that this bishop is
really awful but i get this in very
quickly
okay so that was not so
much of a problem then bishop d7 is
preferable
and i think if i can play this and e6
it's okay yeah e6 bishop b7 bishop c6
and then things should be equal
a6 is clearly a risky move delaying
the development even further
and here i'm under substantial pressure
yeah i wonder if he ever had a knockout
so i'm just going through this
oh bishop g6 wow
what is the idea of the move
is that this one
some kind of tutson the thread is
what exactly what is the thread
a4 is hanging ah e4
just attacks e4 wow
that's a dirty move
yeah and then white is of course clearly
better after this he can take him
and probably check me here i am check
okay but this is still um
this offers very reasonable drawing
chances
probably yeah still he should he should
do that of course
yeah and then it got of course hectic
with the time maybe there were chances
for both sides even
at one point i thought well i can maybe
do something with the
queen side being active up here here
rook h6
is strong threatening clearly rook takes
e6 and it seems that
i have to play rook e7
and then the engine finds this idea
yeah i mean this this position looks
shaky but
clearly we both had a little time
available
so i hear a3 was
strong yeah
this is stronger this one
let's have c2
yeah okay well we don't have we didn't
have much time
a3 was winning again i'm sorry
that was not within my powers i was
quite happy with this position thinking
that
yeah i should win this
king e7 looks completely normal but it's
not good
rook c2 whatever many moves seem to win
yeah quickly push the h pawn the a pawn
i'm sorry
the way it happened here bishop f7 was
even good for white
play for an attack
yeah okay i have to move it and then
this
ah i have no good square actually i i
definitely cannot
take and i must go here and then rook
ff7 that that looks very dangerous
main idea is to play a rook somewhere
here and then made
yeah white would have won there even
and here it's probably a draw unless
there was some
some some huge blunder
just no way to ever win this even though
you have a pawn the right is just far
too active
yeah okay interesting game
probably queen b6 early on this is
better okay
thanks for watching